wir sind unterwegs in Deli kreuz und
quer durch die Stadt me als 30 Millionen
Menschen leben hier viele bitter arm und
doch in manchem der deutschen
Gesellschaft s weit
voraus Zufallsbegegnung auf der Straße
Mohammed AR ist Friseur umgerechnet etwa
10 Cent kostet eine Rasur bei ihm an der
Mauer vor der sein Open Air Laden
aufgebaut hat hängt eine Pappe mit einem
ich nutze das System seit einem Jahr das
Geld geht direkt auf mein Bankkonto es
ist ein gutes System ich habe keine
großen Einnahmen aber sie sind dadurch
etwas
gewachsen und als er seinem Kunden mit
einem Kristallsalz die Haut nach der
Rasur beruhigt ist der schon dabei zu
bezahlen den QRCode mit dem Handy
eingelesen 11 Cent inklusive Trinkgeld
abschicken kurz darauf die
Bestätigung alles ist
bezahlt ich liebe dieses System du
brauchst kein Bargeld mehr wir können
das Geld einfach mit dem Telefon
überweisen auch ganz kleine Summen wenn
wir von jemandem Geld bekommen brauchen
wir dafür nicht mehr zur
Bank zahlen mit dem Handy bargeldlos ist
in Indien in den letzten Jahren völlig
normal geworden jeder macht es und
überall wird es Angeboten Rat stedi
verkauft Mittagessen an Arbeiter aus dem
Kofferraum seines Autos heraus digital
Zen habe enorme Vorteile erzählt er uns
früher haben wir Cash Spargeld genutzt
und es hat immer Probleme gegeben das zu
händeln jetzt mit diesem System geht
alles direkt auf mein Konto das ist das
beste daran das Geld geht direkt auf
mein Konto ich muss mich nicht mehr mit
Bargeld rumschlagen das ist alles sehr
sicher Indien auf dem Weg in die
bargeldlose Volkswirtschaft wir wollen
verstehen was es damit auf sich hat
haben uns mit dem
Wirtschaftswissenschaftler Gautam
chikemane verabredet doch der will erst
einmal etwas loswerden er war gerade in
Berlin hat seine Tochter besucht die
dort
promoviert wir waren absolut geschockt
zu sehen dass nur wenige Läden wie
Coffeeshops oder Restaurants bereit
waren auch nur irgendeine Art digitalen
bezahlen zu akzeptieren wie eine
Kreditkarte oder eine
Bezahlapp wie kommt es dass ein Land wie
Deutschland das einen so großen
Vorsprung vor den meisten anderen hat so
weit hinterher
ist und der Abstand beim eldlosen Zahlen
zwischen Indien nach wie vor eines der
ärbsten Länder der Welt mit einem
bruttoindlandprukt pro Kopf von etwa
2300 und Deutschland im
Wirtschaftsgiganten mit knapp 50 000 ist
enorm um 2019 wurden in Indien 70% aller
Handelsumsätze in Cash abgewickelt 2022
waren es nur noch 27% um Ihnen ein
bisschen Kontext zu geben in Deutschland
sind es
58% eine der denom mitverantwortlich ist
und von profitiert ist das 2010 in Deli
gegründete fintech Unternehmen PTM an
ptms digital Bezahlsystem nehmen
mittlerweile 34 Millionen Geschäfte Teil
vom kleinen Straßenhändler bis zum
Weltkonzern tausende Geschäfte kommen
jeden Tag hinzu hunderte Millionen
Menschen nutzen den Service täglich wir
haben uns am Firmensitz mit rapun aus
derühungsetage von PTM
verabredet will ein Bankkonto aber da
gibt es vor allem in den westlichen
Ländern oft jede Menge Voraussetzungen
die man erfüllen muss eine minimale
mindestinlage z.B jede Menge Papierkram
oft sehr
kompliziert wir bei paytm haben das
alles digitalisiert du kannst eine
digitale Brieftasche haben oder ein
digitales Konto ohne einen Pfennig drauf
zu haben und die Eröffnung dauert nicht
länger als 5
Minuten Transaktionskosten gibt es keine
nicht für den hler nicht für die Kunden
das Geld verdient PTM mit Kreditvergabe
Datenhandel und Geräten die mit den
qrkods verbunden sind etwa 1 € im Monat
kostet das die Händler für den Erfolg
des bargelosen Zahlens aber brauche es
mehr als nur ein Handy und ein QR-Code
erklärt uns
rapun bargeldloses Zahlen braucht eine
Infrastruktur es braucht bezahlbare
mobile Daten sichere
identitätsverifikation und im
Hintergrund andere finanzielle Produkte
wie ein Bankkonto oder eine
elektronische
Börse using them und dafür hat die
indische Regierung in den vergangenen
Jahren gesorgt mobile Daten gehören mit
um die 10 Cent pro Gigabyte zu den
billigsten der Welt und jeder Bürger hat
ein Recht auf ein Bankkonto
Voraussetzung dafür aber ist die
digitale Identität ohne die soll auch in
der öffentlichen Verwaltung bald gar
nichts mehr gehen im ganzen Land
Registrierungsstellen der Regierung dort
werden Fingerabdrücke und ihre Scans
genommen um diese Identität auch
fälschungs sicher zu machen alles läuft
bei der Regierung zusammen aber was ist
eigentlich mit dem
Datenschutz es wird ein neues
Datenschutzgesetz geben das jeden Aspekt
unserer Daten rechtlich schützt sollte
es ein datenl geben wird dann die
Regierung dafür verantwortlich sein
denke
ich die digitale Entwicklung galoppiert
der Gesetzgebung voraus aber für ein
Land das gerade dabei ist sich aus der
Armut zu befreien gibt es sowieso
wichtigeres die Steuereinnahmen sind
Monat für Monat praktisch parallel zum
digitalen bezahlen angestiegen jede
Rupie wird getrackt das heißt nicht dass
es jetzt keine Korruption mehr gibt
wurde sie reduziert auf jeden Fall wird
sie weiter reduziert möglich wird sie
auf Null gehen nicht in der nächsten
Zeit aber langfristig
unausweichlich Indiens
Wirtschaftswachstum liegt dieses Jahr
bei fast 8% und schon bald könnte Indien
zuerst wgeldlosen Volkswirtschaft der
Welt werden dass wir uns das auf den
ersten Blick nur schwer vorstellen
können als W in den straßenelis
unterwegs sind liegt vielleicht daran
dass unser Blick durch so manches
Vorurteil getrübt
ist